so there are reports of a massive
shake-up coming to the Fox News Prime
Time lineup involving Sean Hannity and
Laura Ingram and others those have not
yet been confirmed by Fox news as of
this moment so let's wait on reporting
those what I do want to tell you is that
the latest attempt at a Tucker Carlson
replacement since Tucker Carlson was
fired of course Fox News has gone
through a number of possible trial hosts
this latest guy is the worst of all of
them so far so as a reminder in the
immediate aftermath of the firing of
Tucker Carlson Brian Kilmeade from Fox
and Friends took a shot at it totally
milk toast just not good then Lawrence
Jones came in Lawrence Jones notably not
ready for prime time he tried to come
out aggressive asking tough questions he
looked visibly confused about the
questions he was asking as guests it was
a really big cell phone then Trump's
former press secretary Kylie Kaylee
mcenany a completely self-absorbed to a
delusional Level Playing videos of
herself speaking at some former RNC or
whatever really really bad and now Fox
news this week tried out will Kane
um I'm going to show you decoding Fox
News which is a great Twitter account to
follow decoding Fox News made a
90-second summary of a nine minute
monologue that will Kane did at the top
of last night's show a misogynistic rant
blaming Jill Biden and Giselle fetterman
the wife of Senator John fetterman
blaming them for forcing Joe Biden and
John fetterman to take jobs they can't
handle attacking Senator Dianne
Feinstein it endlessly just did this was
the worst one yet not looking good for
Fox News if this is the best they can
come up with crash it
that is so hard to watch He's incoherent
and if we're being honest
and not worried about being kind that
was one of his better moments from
yesterday that man should not be allowed
to operate a power tool or drive a car
much less govern this country whoa but
as sad as that is for fetterman it's
more sad for the people of Pennsylvania
how did 2.5 million people vote for
fetterman because the alternative was Dr
Oz
what is going on here who is using these
people they're useful idiots for whom
for Jill Biden for Giselle fetterman for
Chuck Schumer
we here in the United States of America
were once led by strong men in America
we were led by Visionaries who not only
won a revolution against an Empire but
had the humility to limit their own
power through Eternal principles
enshrined in a constitution dear God
Titans historic Titans and globally we
were led by men who between glasses of
Brandy and Scotch stared down not only a
tyranny but also weak weaklings on their
own team in order to win a World War
you know we once had Washington and
Jefferson and Madison and now we have
Florida legislatures doing Tick-Tock
dances on The Well of their legislature
body now we have Biden now we have
fetterman now we have Feinstein and yes
for those individuals they are the
victims of ambitious spouses but it's
all their spouses that are to be blamed
so Top Line could not be less newsworthy
could not be more of a snooze Fest to
see will Kane host uh uh Tucker
Carlson's old show here's one other
funny moment he tried to defend the
actions of
um suspended NBA player John Morant and
without even looking at notes Stephen A
Smith explains to will Kane the totality
of what's gone wrong with Morant and it
will Kane just has nothing to say see on
the side of your screen he's flashing a
gun in an Instagram live video I said
earlier this week Stephen A that I don't
think he should be suspended for what
amount to dumb but legal Behavior
everyone Stephen A everyone has
disagreed with me on this count and I
know you do as well yeah because you
know you're usually ill-informed when it
comes to sports matters that's not your
Forte even though you sound great
talking about it but then when we get to
the facts you always got some slippage
there here's the reality of the
situation he's been involved in several
instances he was involved in an incident
last summer where he allegedly got into
an issue with a high school Prospect
came out of his house with a gun there
was another issue involving a friend in
Indianapolis where after a game some
kind of laser red dot laser was being
pointed in the direction of some some
folks with the Indiana Pacers party then
it was the issue he got suspended over
for eight games that cost him over six
hundred thousand dollars now there's
this he had met with the commissioner
Adam Silver the National Basketball
Association looked him dead in his face
and essentially told them this is not me
this is not indicative of my character
and it won't happen again and yet turns
around and this kind of thing happens so
when you're looking at it in a vacuum
and you're thinking about the fact that
no laws were broken no crime was
committed and obviously he plays in the
state I don't know which car where he
was and terms of when he was in the car
for the latest incident but he plays for
the Memphis Grizzlies that's in
Tennessee and obviously in Tennessee you
don't even need a permit to carry so he
didn't break any laws or anything like
that but the NBA is a private industry
and they don't want to be associated
with that because they remember what it
was like in the 80s when the show when
the league was on tape delay will Kane
desperate to try to make some point but
he just knows nothing about this and
Stephen A Smith completely schooling him
so bottom line not ready for prime time
another failed attempt at replacing
Tucker Carlson who's relaunching his
show on Twitter I guess very soon it
will be very interesting to see What
Becomes of the new Fox News lineup but I
don't think will Kane is going to be the
steward of that new Prime Time lineup
and ratings not good sometimes it can be
tough to maintain an emotional
connection with your significant other
you might work in different places at
different times there might be a kid in
the way it can be hard to find time for
date nights especially because kids
demand so much attention which which is
why I love our sponsor paired which is
the app for couples the app will prompt
you with a daily question or a game or a
guided conversation all designed by
Leading psychologists and the point is
to just have a deeper connection with
your partner boost intimacy build a
deeper knowledge of one another my
girlfriend and I will use the prompts on
paired throughout the day to stay
connected for instance we answered a
prompt about what we remember most from
the early days of the relationship it
really helps us learn new things and
there can be funny moments as well an
independent study found that couples
using paired saw 36 percent increase in
the quality of their relationship and
giving a paired subscription as a gift
is also a really great idea you can try
it free for seven days and get 25 off a
subscription go to pair.com Pacman the
link is in the description thank you